If a man calls his wife to bed and she
refuses and he goes to sleep angry with
her, the angels curse her until morning.
This is disgusting.
>> This is a statement of
I'm telling you sister. My dear sister,
this is what we mean. My dear sister,
>> just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well in welcome to
this reaction video. So, this was a
video that I saw. By the way guys, let's
introduce Hazim.
>> You know, sometimes I get into my videos
so intensely. I'm so passionate. One
brother, one brother goes, you know,
brother, last video you didn't introduce
the I was like, yeah, I totally forgot.
But I don't need to. You know what? She
the angels know you. That's why.
>> Alhamdulillah. So, brother and sisters,
Adam, we're going to be reacting to a
video of this sister.
>> When I watched this, I got I got really
upset. I got really angry.
>> Why? Why? Why?
>> I got angry for the sake of Allah.
Nothing to do with that. You know, I was
thinking, how do I go about this? Should
I be ruthless or should I be and and
there was a video that I saw of hers
where she's like, oh, you know, I know
there's some people upset with me, but
instead of this, come with mercy. I
thought, you know what? I'm going to
tone it down a bit. I'm going to try to
be as reasonable as I can, but I'm also
going to show her through her video that
this proves herself.
>> We're going to come to So, here's a
video where she this sister is venting
out. I've been looking at because
usually when I speak about someone, I go
to the Tik Tok and try to understand the
psychology where they're coming from.
So, there are certain things with the
sister. For example, one thing that I
saw was this post. In this post, she
says, "Just a South Asian breaking
general
>> generational generation,
>> so generational curses, taboos, and
feeling uh and through it all,
>> feeling through it all. This path isn't
for everyone. This is a proof. You can
come out of the other side, etc. So, you
see when she said generational curse,
this is a typical, if I'm not mistaken,
she's Bengali. She looks Bengali." Yeah.
By the way,
>> well, she says she's South Asian. Let's
No problem. I'm just saying Bangladesh,
Pakistan, whatever. The point is this.
>> Sometimes with those communities, it
happens. Yes. The way they use culture
over Islam.
>> No,
>> it happens. So, it seems like there's a
trauma from there. So, I'm going to
assume the best by saying she comes from
a trauma from that post. Here's a video
she done and she made Islam look like an
absolute misogynistic womanhating, woman
bashing. You absolut like as if the
woman like like basically what pre-Islam
how women were valued. She made it seem
as if that was Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> Here's a video and let's see what is her
intentions.
>> Talk about the difference between
pre-Islam and Islam.
>> Oh yes. We're going we're going to see
if Islam is against women or for woman.
We're going to see. Let's let's see for
ourselves. In here's the video.
>> Why can't women lead prayer? Why are
women told to hide but men can roam
freely?
>> Okay, one second. So firstly, let's stop
there because this is going to be a long
video guys. Stick through inshallah. Why
can Look, the first premise is this. Why
can men lead prayer?
>> No. Why can't
>> why can't women lead prayer?
>> No problem. Firstly, woman can lead
other women, but why can't uh woman lead
prayer?
>> Okay, look look the one thing. Do you
know the position of a woman when she's
leading other women? Where does she
stand?
>> No,
>> she stand in line with them in the
middle.
>> Yeah.
>> She doesn't go and do imam in front of
them.
>> Yes.
You know in in our in our jury prudence
>> there is the line
>> she stands in the middle.
>> Yeah.
>> And they pray in one line. She doesn't
even with women. She doesn't even Now
now let's see this.
>> A woman is leading man in prayer.
>> Yeah.
>> You understand what I mean?
>> So that means that other women should be
in line with man.
>> Okay. And let's imagine she goes into
>> Yeah. and her minces come.
>> Yeah.
>> That means she can't pray.
>> Well, she can't pray. But but then
again, minces, we're talking about
blood. Yeah.
>> What about if her minces are heavy and
the blood ends up on the carpet and all
over the masjid and that
>> Yeah, that's exactly that's one point as
well. Not only that,
>> and what she's going to do when she's
pregnant, heavily pregnant.
>> No, no, exactly. These are the points
we're going to come to later with the
premise I want to ask is this. Why is it
that you your criteria of success is a
is a man? Why does feminism have to say
my target and my aim is to be a to be
like a man?
>> Why do you want to be a man?
>> Not only be a man, why do you want to be
like a man? Why is it that you want to
be like a man? Why can't it be yourself?
Do you get what I'm trying to say? This
is why it's very important. And she's
talking about, oh, why can't they lead?
Why not? For example, why is a lead a a
privilege but not a responsibility? Yes.
Why isn't that leadership is a
responsibility that you will be
accountable for rather than a perk? Why
does leadership leadership let me tell
you something here leadership look I
have there certain projects that I lead
it is not easy dealing with people I'll
be it's so hard you've got so much on
your shoulders sometimes like I wish I I
don't lead this somebody else man or I
just I do editing because it's such a
big amount but let's carry on in another
thing she said about oh men can roam
free yeah I cover up sorry as a Muslim
man my dear sister I have to cover from
my naval to my knee when I go swimming
when I go out with my family or swimming
whatever it is I cover up I don't find
the bottom so long that I cover I wear a
shirt. I have I have a shirt.
>> Speedo wearing a speedo.
>> Exactly. So I wear something that covers
my top. So this thing of only women have
to cover up and men don't is absolutely
nonsense. I can't wear tights leggings
or tight tight jeans or tight clothes.
I'm not allowed to, you know. So but
anyways, let's lower our gaze.
>> Yes, we're going to come to that.
>> There is
>> Yeah, we're going to come to that in
>> Why are women still getting shamed by
these imams and scholars because we're
simply existing? Why does men have to be
ex and why do men always Let me tell you
something. I have done more videos and
many we advise many YouTubers, many
brothers in the YouTube scene, we have
advised and given a sea. Go and look at
my content. Do you see me specifically
targeting sisters I give to both genders
and I take both account accountable for
so I don't know what you mean by it's
always always it seems like she's
projecting as if she's gone through
something specific and she thinks
everybody's like that. I don't know
where she gets that from.
Why does a man have to be involved in
every single spec of our life?
>> I hope you guys enjoy the video, guys.
But before that, please download the
Salah Pro app. Brothers and sisters, we
are a charity. All of our services on
the app is for free. Free kiblinder, no
ads, free salah reminders, encourages to
pray, tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah, salah hubs, and
many, many more brother sisters. We are
not an app that shares your information
with third parties. All of our services
on the app is for free. Download it now
inshallah and enjoy guys. Another thing
she says, why are men involved in every
respect of our life? Because you guys
are vulnerable. When you are pregnant,
you have to be protected. This entire
world, the roads that you drive on, the
buildings, all this who who built it?
Men built it. Does this mean we built it
so we can just enjoy it? No. We built it
so our wives, the woman folk can use it
as well. So when you talk like this as
if they're in control in control of what
you when you walk down the road at night
time what does your mom or fathers tell
you don't go out at night why would my
father or my mother say that to me I
have a I'm a man I can be involved in m
whatever it is for that matter I can
defend myself you as a woman you are
vulnerable so when you come and say in
Islam why is it always involved because
Islam is looking for your greater good
let me tell you why go to the western
system to the western world you've got
women who are out there in the dating
world. And guess what's happening? They
are being used and abused like it's
happy days. They're being used and
abused by men. Why? Because he's giving
them false promises. Get him what he
wants. Treats him like a toilet and
says, "I'm bored of you. Bye-bye." And
guess what? Who will take that man to
account? Another man. Another man will
come and say, "Hold on a second. That's
why Islam has come to protect you, my
sister, that you are so against your
father, your brother." Why? Because a
man knows a man. We're not emotional
creatures. We're logical. Women are
bound to be emotional. They have their
strengths. They have their weaknesses.
As a man, I have daughters. I've got
three daughters. I have a wife. I've got
a mother. I know how my daughters, my
wife, and my mother can be. They're
emotional. And this is absolutely
normal. It's in their nature to be like
that. So, the feminine is a flow. And
they need something that is certain like
a man to lead.
>> You know, you know,
>> so I don't find why she's complaining
about her. Oh, he's controlling. It's
controlling your life. Allah has given
the man to protect and serve you. Uh,
>> brother Ali. Subhan Allah. Look at one
thing.
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala created the
woman.
>> Yeah.
>> And he knows it's her nature. Yeah.
That's it's his own creation. So why
isn't tal in the hand of women?
>> Because my wife will divorce me uh 75
times a day.
>> 100 times a day.
>> Exactly. Why? Not because she means
>> you wake up. You wake up.
>> I I'm getting divorced while I'm
sleeping.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> So why Ali? because it shows that Allahh
you know what's very interesting even
the talaq being in our hand is a
responsibility because inah before Islam
the men used to give divorce and take
the back give divorce take her back as
he pleased messing around with it
>> and how many how many women says that
Allah legislated it to three so it's a
check for a man in the sense where if
you give the falak she has to go and
marry another man be intimate then come
and now for a man that's a big
Yeah.
>> So what does that mean? It's actually
there the are there to keep the man in
check.
>> Exactly. And if he gives a
>> protect the woman to protect the woman
from an abuser.
>> Exactly. And not only that, if he gives
a faq and he can't come and say, "Oh,
you can't move on." He say, "Oh, shut
up, my friend." Islam says she's moving
on and you can do nothing about it.
Absolutely.
>> I'm going to come and say, "Why is
Allah, how could Allah, like she said,
the audacity in the video, I'm going to
say the audacity." the audacity, you
know, that's very dangerous because
because audacity who who said the hadith
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and she said how how can he have the
audacity
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasall me
going to the messenger of Allah he
saying hadith and I go how dare you say
the wall is and I'm not saying you're a
I'm saying the statement statement let's
carry on
>> and if you're going to give me the
excuse of oh it's to protect you then
why are many women essayed by their
close family members
So just because woman there's been a
sexual assault. Yes. By their close
family members depends what you mean by
close family members. Okay. Your mahum
is who? Your father, your brother, your
uncle, your granddad. Do you understand?
So generally it's not. But if you're
talking about that even certain stuff
the the um
>> incest. She's talking about incest.
>> Yeah. Or abuse etc. Depends what you're
talking about. You can't come and paint
everyone the same. again. Show me what
is wrong with Islam dictating a man to
be your full time. Forget your culture.
I'm not talking about your culture.
Please, I'm talking about Islam. Put
your culture to aside. I'm talking about
Islam. Don't mix your culture with Islam
for that matter. But let's carry on in
>> the truth is uncomfortable. Not Islam
itself, but the way patriarchy has
seeped in and wrapped itself around
religion that we can't even tell the
difference anymore. And if you question
as a woman, you're possessed. The
devil's gotten to you.
>> So she talks about if your question, so
she talks about personal experience in
another video. She went to an imam, etc.
She asked some questions and the imam
said, "You're possessed. You got Shayan
in you." Okay, he's wrong. He's wrong.
What kind of answer is that? You got
Shayan in you. But why are you labeling
everyone?
>> Look, look, look, look. You know, she
reminds me of the, you know, the famous
hadith in Sah Bkari of the man that
killed 99.
He went
>> to this to this to this cleric who was
in in some kind of monastery and he was
all he does he he knows nothing. All he
knows is worship. When he asked him he
said to him you have no Toba. So he
killed him.
>> But when he went to the scholar
>> yes
>> the scholar advised him. It's not that
he went to an imam. There are some
people who are imams and all they know
is salah and what relates to salah. But
you ask them a question out of the realm
of their knowledge they will not know
how to answer. So absolutely when you
want to seek something seek it from the
proper channels through the proper
channels
>> and don't label everyone the same
>> the same. Let me tell you something. I
the stuff that you're going to bring up
now about hadith. We've done videos on
this. We will answer it with with ease,
with happiness. But don't blame label
everyone the same.
>> You need to go and pray. God forbid a
woman has her own brain and question
things that just don't seem right. These
are some of my favorite hadith. I'm
going to share it with you and you tell
me if it fits right with you.
>> Okay. Interesting. These are some of my
hadith. And now she's going to ask,
"Does this sit right with you?" meaning
>> but but she's saying women how dare
women question
>> subhan allah women subhan allah look the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam with
his wife
>> wives
>> they questioned something and then
>> subhan allah these the mothers of the
believers
>> the the com if you look into the the s
of the prophet or or the companions of
the prophet you will see how their women
Sure.
>> Not only that, they were questioned the
praise the unsulli woman for question on
intimate stuff.
>> Yes.
>> They didn't come and say, "Oh, you are
like the Christians." They were deciding
if the woman has a soul. Yes. Or we be
will be in front to to the river. If she
if she drowns, she's not a witch. No,
she's not a witch. But if she doesn't
drown, they burn her alive. So you die.
You die.
>> They do give you a dog. Yes. Like like
in the Judaism, you can't even get a
divorce unless your husband gives it to
you. And if you have got your minces,
you cannot touch your husband or
anything that you touch has to be
washed.
>> And what did the prophetam do? The
opposite. When his wife were in minces,
he would show affection in different
ways. Absolutely. So my dear sister, you
have no idea about Islam and the rights
of thing. And what you've done, you
further
>> the right of women in Islam.
>> Exactly. And what you've done, you've
gone out there emotionally driven,
sadly. And Yeah. And you've gone out
there and made Islam look bad. And this
is one of the reasons why women have to
be led because you have emotional moment
and you say things you don't mean. Every
single one of us are married to a woman.
Come on, Muslim or non-Muslim for that
matter. Come on. Do not come and tell me
that woman go and don't say. I know my
wife, she will say certain stuff and
then she'll come and say, you know what,
I don't know why I said that. It's
normal. It is it happens as men. We are
told to be patient. So it it's it's a
weakness within a woman and that is a
reality. But let's carry on. Shall let's
see what's the problematic hadith that
she has. The problem is within yourself,
not Islam. You have been told liberalism
and feminism that's been indoctrinated
in your mind. So much so that you think
there's a problem with Islam. There's a
problem with you, my dear sister, not
with Islam.
>> A people who make a woman their ruler
will never be successful.
>> Yes. What's your point? What's your
point?
>> The prophet said this.
>> Yes. And also what's what's your
problem? What is your problem? For
example, how is a woman going to lead?
Yes. When she's on a menis. Yes. When
her emotions are affected, there's
imbalances, hormone imbalances. You need
to make decision factors pertaining to
warfare. Number one. Number two,
>> economy.
>> Economy. Many stuff. Not only that, not
stuff. For example, when it comes to um
uh um pregnancy, what if you're
pregnant?
>> Can you imagine? We come to you and say
you are the leader. I'm pregnant. No,
no, no, no, no. The affairs of this is a
blessing for you. It is a blessing for
you that that a man is given to the man.
But but but but brother Ali, let's not
forget it doesn't mean that women don't
contribute in opinion and that you
remember in the uh inabia
>> when the when when when the Sahaba or
the Sahabah were upset because they
couldn't do um and stuff
>> who advised the prophet
>> to shave and slaughter the sacrif the
sacrificial animal.
>> Which one?
>> His wife is the one giving am she's the
one that gave him this opinion and the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam acted
upon her advice
>> and subhan allah he didn't say oh you're
a woman how how dare you and I'm prophet
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
>> yes even was known to be very harsh when
he was yeah in the in the story of
pertaining to woman's right of mahi when
he said meant you you're making it too
expensive that men can't get married.
What did a woman come and stand up in in
the government?
>> Yeah. She told him and he said Omar got
it wrong and a woman was right.
>> And this is Islam. This is Islam.
>> He didn't say how dare you I am the
leader of of look the um at that time we
had the Persian, we had the Levant. It
was so
>> you know
>> it's like you can come and say I'm
ruling all this and you want as a woman
he allowed he listened he said you're
right and I am wrong. Not only that the
fact that you are doing this video being
absolutely misinformed misinforming
others giving Islam a bad reputation
shows that as a woman you emotionally
got driven and did something which you
should have not done.
Unfortunately, if she would have gone if
she would have gone to the commentary on
the hadith, she would have understood on
the commentary of the hadith.
>> Yes.
>> What the scholars say about it.
>> Exactly. So, let's go. That's the reason
why women have to be led. It's like
that. I believe in the nuclear family.
It's as simple as that. The men is the
head of the house. It's as simple as
that. I don't believe in this thing. The
greatest form of the greatest form of um
inequality is to treat unequal things
equally. And if she thinks that the
western world is different, let's see in
in
the epistles of of Paul,
>> the head of the woman is
>> Yes. is the husband.
>> Is the man.
>> Yes.
>> The head of the woman is the man.
>> Even in other religions,
>> Yes. No. And not only that, the western
woman was fighting for their rights to
own property. Their husbands could sell
them if they were in debt. In debt in
the market, they could sell them. Not
only that they didn't have a right to
work. They didn't have inherited
>> even the voting in system and even they
would have to take their husband's um
surname. Yes. In Islam
>> still until today until today. Yes.
Again if you studied your religion
sister instead of cultural backgrounds
whatever that you went through you would
not be making this uh video. That's
embarrassing for you.
>> Sah Al Bkari 4425
openly borrow woman from leadership. If
I were to order anyone to prostrate to
anyone, I would have ordered women to
prostrate to their husbands
159.
>> And yes, okay. What's what's the issue
with that? What's the issue with that?
The narration clearly says that one of
the comp if no
he was in the Yeah.
>> He comes to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and because he has seen
clerics.
>> Yes. in their
prostrating uh people prostrating to
their clerics. So he tells the he tells
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
after he prostrated then the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said if I
were to ask anybody to prostrate to
someone else I would have asked the
reason why why look
>> what she does not understand you have to
understand Islamah in the Quran says
that the most noble of you in the sight
of Allah are the righteous one does that
mean if a woman is more righteous than
me. I'm better than her in the sight of
Allah.
>> Exactly.
>> So, so this is in the Quran. The Quran
answers her.
>> Yes.
>> Answers her.
>> Exactly.
>> But it's the right of the husband like
>> can your wife do you make your wife pay
the rent?
>> No.
>> Pay the bills.
>> No, I would say the audacity. One
second. Why am I paying the rent? Why am
I doing the shopping? Why am I changing
the tire? Why am I doing something?
Allah is my witness. I got a cupboard
for my wife like to put her clothing
etc. Yeah. Okay. Do you know how long it
took me to do it? Take a guess. Take it
guess I cuz they told me it's £250 to
have two people to come in. I pay £250.
Do you know how long it took me? Guess
how many hours?
>> Two days.
>> It took me Sheh nearly 14 hours straight
straight straight 14 hours she to do the
whole thing.
>> I can come and say why am I doing this?
>> Yeah,
>> you do it man.
>> Half everything. Half, not half, half,
you do it. Not only that, when I walk
down the road with my wife and somebody
says something to my wife,
>> you protect yourself.
>> Whose neck? Whose neck is on?
>> Why am I protecting you? Guess what? If
I protect you and I die
>> and you have a right to go get married
again, I can come and say I'm going to
die and on top of that, subhan, you're
going to get married again. I can say
no. Why? Like do like the Hindus. When
the man dies, burn the woman with you.
Habibi, go. Yes. I'm going to come and
say, for example, when a war happens,
the feminists don't want to know. What
the fist say? Take us back to the
kitchen. That's what that's what they
say. No, no, no. We we want to cook. We
want to cook now in Ukraine. What's
going on? Do we as men come and say what
kind of audacity? Why is Allah this?
What kind of religion is this that
always favors the woman? Wall go and
look. I dare you. Come on. There's so
many examples that we can give. Why am I
paying for that mah? Why am I Why did
she pay me mah?
>> Yeah.
>> She married a man like me. She should
pay me mah.
>> No, I want mah as well.
>> No, I'm the one who's paying mah. I'm
doing the wedding. I'm paying for
everything. Guess what? If she goes and
works, her money is her money.
>> Yes.
>> What kind? Do you see what I'm saying?
Sh.
>> And you know, you know, you know, you
know, in the jury prudence of doing this
video,
>> you know, in the jury prudence,
>> if you marry a a rich woman,
>> you have to to to to
you she has to live up to her standard.
>> Yes. To her standard. So it means that
you go and work so hard. Yes.
>> It's not I'm poor is this is all she has
the right to live up to her standards
cuz it's your fault marrying a rich
woman.
>> Exactly. So you have to do that. Subhan
Allah. And not only that, her mah is her
security. If for example I leave her and
say bye-bye. Guess what? She has a
security to fall back on. What does the
woman have here? Deadbeat men sleeping
around disappearing. And then guess
what? They have to go and beg the
government. And these women have to be a
man and a woman in the household. Let's
carry on in
>> like Kina Stroke Michael.
>> Yeah, exactly. Let's see. Let's see how
oppressive women are in Islam. Let's
carry on.
>> The absolute audacity.
>> This is a statement of
I'm telling you sister. My dear sister,
this is what we mean. My dear sister,
believe me, I was going to be a lot
harsh in this video if I didn't watch
your videos on TikTok and to be like,
you know what, she's got trauma
somewhere. And you've even said that
there you suffering from narcissism
yourself. Okay, no problem. You are a
sister still the damage that you caused
based on your emotional decisions. Okay,
believe me wallah if you spoke to a man
again I'm not belittling there are
instances where we as men have
weaknesses if you spoke to a man they
would have given you and say listen you
may want to do this and vent out because
of something you went through but how is
this going to make Islam look my dear
sister before you move on emotions but
no so the very video that you're doing
proves that you need men in your life as
much as we need our wife you need men in
your life for leadership qualities men
have that that's our strength and lord
logic and rationale. Let's carry on
>> of obedience. I have not left behind me
any fitna trial more harmful to men than
women.
>> Yes. And what's the what's the point?
What's the point? There is no bigger
fitna. Yes. Yes. Women are the biggest
fit. Now, what does fit mean? Does that
mean fit meanan? No. It means the
greatest trial for us, the biggest
weakness for a man is what? It's a
woman. So, I don't understand what's the
issue. For example, you have as woman,
you guys have weakness of what? Wanting
to look attractive. My sister, I'll ask
you a question and say to you, "Sorry,
why is your hijab not on properly? Why
have you got makeup on?"
>> Why?
>> Yeah. Was it was it why you say, "Oh,
but it's a weak." H Oh, okay. So, if the
prophet said the greatest weakness for a
uh woman is for a man or whatever.
>> Yes. So, what I'm saying is you have
weaknesses. We're saying that the
biggest thing that if you see what is
the biggest tools people are put in in
in its context
researching it man
what does people like you know the epist
island idols yes
>> who were they using
>> they using
>> they were using sadly these innocent
girls why because these deranged men yes
and not only that some use prostitutes
they use really attractive women to get
what men it's the oldest trick in the
You know why? Because men fall for what?
>> Beauty. Just the way you What do you
woman fall for? A man of status,
strength, fame, this that. That's your
weakness. Imagine. Anyways, anyway, so
I'm a bit passionate, but let's carry
on.
>> 509 Sah Muslim 2740.
>> The woman is and when she goes out, the
devil looks at her.
>> I've never heard of this. I don't know
why she said that.
>> No, no,
>> I've never heard. I don't know what it
is.
>> No, no. The hadith that the woman when
she goes not that the devil she goes
with the shaitan and comes back with the
shaitan.
>> Yeah.
>> Not that the devil looks at her.
>> Okay.
>> But what it means what it means
a woman is a
>> yes.
>> If a woman like we see now I mean we we
have all seen this new fashion now of
wearing very tight shorts. Everything is
showing
>> dressed but naked.
>> Dressed but naked.
>> That's what it means. M
>> a woman is
>> any little thing would cause fa
and that's and that's that's a reality
that the reality is this Allah has
created you
>> in a desirable way that is how it is
it's not blame attraction in the man the
man toward women
>> exactly that's for procreation and other
reasons if it's done the right way so
Allah has made you like that now for
example would you like it and I'll give
an example for example would you like it
that when you're out and about with your
husband. There are women who have
extremely beautified yourself and not
only that dressed half naked and you
know that's a weakness that's that's a
weakness is going to attract your
husband. Now you might come and say why
can't he control his gaze? Of course he
should. But let me give it I'll flip it.
I'll flip it. No problem.
>> You go out you and your husband go out.
Your husband is not earning that much.
It's not. And then on the forehead of
men you can see how much they value
that.
>> 1 million 1.2 million. Is that not going
to be a fitness for you?
>> Are you not going to be like you know
what? Oh my gosh. that I should have I
should have had married him. You know
what? He can give me a good laugh. Look,
he's worth 1.2 million. He's worth
300,000. That is the same thing for us
as men. We're seeing we want to protect
ourselves, but don't rub it in my face.
So, the point is when it's a woman, it's
you don't blame. Oh, it's a man's fault.
But then, wouldn't women start comparing
and saying, "Oh my gosh, I don't want to
see it. It's her right." Because it's a
fitna for her. But but look, she's
talking in Jahyah in Jahyah when Islam
came and put every put the house in
order. Yes. The house was a mess. Islam
came and put it in order.
>> Do you know that when the father used to
die, his son inherits everything,
inherits his slaves, his his maids,
>> he would inherit even his mother. Yes.
>> His mother becomes his property. Subhan
Allah.
>> Property. Islam came and ordered. They
used to bury little girls
>> alive
and Islam has come and look how you have
made your religion look like it's the
opposite because of your because your
emotion
>> ti 1173 if we're not the devil then who
are men you're literally telling on
yourselves
>> the way she talks about a hadith of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
>> she has no respect you can see there's
there's trauma involved you can see
clearly the way she's talking about the
hadith definitely there's some trauma
involved
>> I saw hell and I had Never seen anything
more horrific. I saw that most of its
inhabitants were women. Sah Bkari.
>> Yes. Okay. No problem. When that's
that's that's reality.
>> But she never finished the
>> Yes. The hadith. Exactly.
>> What does the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
>> they curse so much.
>> Yes.
>> Why
and the woman you can
>> look we all have been through this.
Yeah,
>> a woman you can do everything to do to
her.
>> Yes.
>> All the good things. The day you will
make a mistake, she forgets all the good
things and she'll attack you for that
mistake you have made. That's what the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
meant. Exactly.
>> And what
women
are known to be backbiters. Yeah.
>> More than men. Yeah. Because you know
why? They also talk more than men. Yeah.
They have to express more.
>> And they leave. You know, there's
studies that show this woman to woman.
Do you know how lethal they are to each
other? She they know women know. Do you
know how much women hate and in
competition with each other? There's
studies that show they are ruthless. She
they are ruthless. There was a woman
when I used to Uber I picked up a nurse,
two nurses in the back of the car. She's
crying and I was like air dropping. I
was thinking why is she crying? She goes
there's rumors going on with her other
colleague nurses saying she's having an
affair with a man in another doctor.
>> Another doctor. Yeah. And I was and in
Islam what is one of the greatest
slander to a chase woman. I can come and
say why why doesn't it say a man you
know you know
>> why doesn't it say a man you know you
know what's the the punishment for that
80 lashes
>> I can come and say why does it say that
if a chase woman is slundered I want to
know why doesn't it say a man because
Islam knows a woman being slandered is
worse
>> than so I can come and say why doesn't
it say a man because for a man it's
something to be boasted in the sense
where of oh you know whatever it is he's
got many women in his life Islam deals
with each individual specifically Not
one shoe fits all.
>> Look, look how Islam elevated the woman.
>> Now in Quran chapter chapter 4, what is
it?
>> Isa
is there?
>> No. No. Explain what that means. What's
>> women?
>> What does mean?
>> Women. Men.
>> One second. So there is a whole chapter
in the Quran about women.
>> Yes.
>> But not men.
>> Not men.
>> The audacity.
How? One second. Let me go with what the
sister says.
>> The author of the Quran. The author of
the Quran.
And another thing chapter chapter
chapter three
>> is Iran the family of Imran
>> but the family of Imran you would you
would think that Allahh is going to talk
about the man
>> husband no it says Mariam
>> he's talking about the mother of Miriam
>> yes the mother yes
>> and he's talking about Miriam
>> yes
>> but he doesn't talk about Iran Iran he
doesn't talk about him he talk about his
wife
>> yes
>> and so on and so forth
>> see this misogynistic religion
So misogynistic, unbelievable. And Allah
says very clearly and believe me, I
speak to couples who have issues etc.
Believe me. Wallah, let me tell you
something. It is a known phenomena
across the globe. You will do so much
for your wife.
She say one wrong. I've never seen any
good from you. And let me tell you
something. How explain there are I know
non-Muslims who hear this and they go
your prophet said that. She was he has
to be prophet of god. This is a reality.
It shows and what did the the the woman
say and the prophet gave them a
solution. He said give in.
>> They didn't come and say the audacity
they didn't fall into kufur. They looked
for a solution. Solution was what? Give
more doing good deeds.
>> Look the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam before on his last breath. Yes.
On his last breath
>> he said
because he said that the woman should be
fully slave to her husband.
>> He said
salah salah prayer prayer and take care
of women.
>> Ah this the audacity the audacity
>> take care of women. the audacity
>> on the last the last the last the sermon
of the sermon of
>> the of
>> the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is talking about how we should be with
women he didn't say how women should be
with men he said how men should be with
women
>> exactly exactly what did he say he said
that they're like a bent rib if you try
to strain them you'll break it yes so
person of being gentle even when it
comes to intimacy the prophet mentioned
everything and how he was with his wives
is a fine example but did you research
this
>> look no look let's not when when fatim
came to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
>> very angry because Ali was going to
marry the daughter of Abu Jah
>> the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
got angry for his daughter
>> and he went
>> and he did a on the member
Yeah.
>> They said by Allah that he it's not
going to happen.
>> Yeah. That's why he was enemy of Allah.
>> The daughter the daughter of
Allah cannot be under the same.
>> So so so why the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam didn't say to her that's
your husband and you have to obey.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. And not only
that,
>> one thing that I forgot to mention about
prostrating, if I ask anyone to
prostrate, it will be the husband is be
the wife to the husband is because of
the responsibility the man has on the
day of judgment. The man of the house is
going to be questioned. I can come and
say why doesn't my wife get questioned.
>> The audacity I'm the one that's the
protector, the provider, the bread
winner. I'm the one that changes the
tire, electric issue, this issue, that
issue, fix this, fix that. The there's a
responsibility when we think about that.
You're Let me be honest. You have loads
of respect. I don't know the sister and
I'm trying to be careful here. Maybe one
of your family members, whoever it is,
I'm not going to get a male, has done
something bad, whatever. And you think
Allah is talking about that man. You
think Allah, Allah's messenger is
talking about to bow down to a man like
that. What are you talking about?
Seriously. Seriously. Let's carry on.
>> Bkari 1052 Muslim 2737.
God.
If a woman dies whilst her husband is
pleased with her, she will enter
paradise. Men, men, men. It's all to do
with men. Are you not seeing this?
>> Are you not seeing this? You're you're
I'm so sorry. You are so ignorant. I've
we've just pointed out to you all the
stipulations, the rulings pertaining to
against men in that sense. If you think
about if you're going to use it, it's
against men. Yeah. Okay. Why you not
talking about that? And here, what's the
look at this look at this? Look at the
reward. If you pray your salah,
>> if you pray your fives,
>> your fives
>> and fast your your month and keep your
chastity.
>> Yes. You and and obey your husband. You
enter Jenna from whichever gate.
>> Whichever. So there are people
>> and there are eight gates.
>> Yes. And you are going to give me that
privilege. Why? Because it show
>> pray to Allah that that the hadith was
for men. I would obey my wife. I would
obey her to enter Jenna.
>> Exactly. And not only that enter Jenna,
>> it shows you that
>> the the the the nature of woman there's
ingratitude there. Yes. There's
sometimes rebellionist there. And
because of the emotions you say things
that you don't I mean like look
sometimes even on social media as we
said on social media you see woman
coming and saying when I'm on my menises
everything about my husband I hate.
>> Yeah.
>> So can you imagine if they will label
that as psychological abuse if I come
and say you
>> Yeah. Yeah. No whatever it is. So
imagine if I was to come and say when
I'm going through my hormonal
imbalances, I just hate my wife's guts
and I just, you know, some of them what
they do, they do videos saying, "Oh, um,
I'm on my menises, my wife, my husband
has a good time. I'm going to go ruin
his day."
>> And people are laughing. Imagine if I
said that and I go, "Yeah, I'm having a
bad day. I'm going to go on ruin wall."
They will say, "You're an evil
narcissist, manipulating, gaslighting,
da da da da da da all for some odd
reason."
>> Always the men are the narcissist for
some odd reason. Women are never the
narcissist. Yeah. But you never talk
about this. Why do you talk about all of
the responsibilities that's on the man's
shoulders? Nope. Totally ignore that.
This the reason why Allah subhanaa tala
has given that degree over the man
because the man has responsibilities.
It's not a privilege. It's not a perk.
It is a responsibility that I will be
accounted on the day of judgment. So
what are you crying about? You are
served from when you're born. Your dad
takes care of you. Then your brother,
then your husband, then your son. You
are being taken care of from the moment
you are born till you die. And you have
an issue with that. Allah say
alhamdulillah for Islam.
>> You know in Islam,
>> yeah,
>> for example, if you divorce and you've
got daughters,
>> Yes.
>> and you got a son.
>> When the son reaches puberty, you don't
have to pay the maintenance. I'm talking
about paying maintenance.
>> But for the girls, you pay maintenance
until they get married.
>> The audacity. She the audacity. And what
is it? When you have the free daughters
and you look after them,
>> Jenna,
>> the audacity. Why doesn't he say free
men? The audacity.
>> And the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said two daughters and then he
reduced it to one
>> to one. The audacity. The audacity men.
You know I'm going to say woman womanh.
What's going on? Woman woman. Woman
woman. woman woman.
>> You reminded me a a young man comes to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
He said, "Oh Allah, who is more
deserving of my companionship?"
Look, Men, men again
>> beside uh your mother.
>> Okay. Then your father.
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> Your mother.
>> Okay. After your father.
>> Then your father.
>> Three times woman and then a man. The
audacity. Why is it always woman woman?
>> Jenna is at the feet of your mother.
>> Woman woman. W woman.
>> Now there that's where Jenna is.
>> Sheh. I've had enough. The audacity.
Look at this wall. If you studied your
religion, if you just studied your
religion, you would have never made this
complete statements. You would have made
a mockery of your religion and do it the
biggest disservice. And this is an
evidence within itself why women have to
be led.
>> But isn't this we heard all this from
palemicists
>> of course
>> from from Islam. I thought she was an
Islam. I thought she's a fake Muslim.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because that's where the
pmicists come to us with to to to we we
wake week in week out. We deal with this
>> on the DA table.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Again, one of my favorites that many try
to interpret, but it still never makes
sense at the end of the day. If a man
calls his wife to bed and she refuses
and he goes to sleep angry with her, the
angels curse her until morning. This is
disgusting.
Guilt tripping women into doing sexual
actions with doesn't want to. It's
solely based on pleasing men. wall
that's a statement of kufur. It could
even take you to the foot of Islam. You
are basically saying what the messenger
of Allah said
>> it's not it's good it it's not it's good
it takes
>> it takes I'm not saying you're kir I'm
saying that statement there you've just
called the messenger of Allah disgusted
this is the message of Allah this what
I'm saying Allah says in the Quran when
Allah and his messenger decide the
matter it is not for the believers
>> befitting the believing man and woman
>> to disagree
>> disagree and let me tell you
This is this is going to show you my
dear sister how how ignorant you know
you know why this hadith is actually the
opposite way cuz what does the hadith
say if a man calls his wife to bed a
wife yes now let's reverse it what if it
was a woman wants intimacy and calls her
husband and by the way in Islam we know
what if the man doesn't give her
intimate rights does she have a right to
divorce
>> she has woman woman again oh my god she
doesn't say to divorce we say to anal
the marriage divorce. So let me get this
right. If a woman is not sexually
satisfied and this happened at the time
of the prophetam
>> no no no what sexually sexually
satisfied
no maintenance if if you don't bring the
food if you don't bring the food if you
don't pay the
>> only they said that you can even go and
take from his pocket.
>> Yes. Imagine
>> the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
allowed him the the wife of Abu Sufyan
because Abu Sufu was miseract
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said but take what is enough for you
and your children take enough take
enough
>> exactly
>> from but he didn't say to take from her
money
>> good now it says the hadith says if you
call your wife now let's put this into
perspective as a Muslim man I fear Allah
I can't go and sleep around.
>> Yes.
>> I can't go and have one night stands.
>> I can't go and mess around. Meaning the
only place that I can get my interrise
is from who?
>> From your wife.
>> My wife. Okay. Good. And the only place
she can interize with is who?
>> Your husband.
>> Which means she relies on me. The way I
rely on her. Meaning, for example, at
her most weakest. For example, at my
wife's most weakest is what? Physical
combat. If a man comes to her, tries to
attack her, she can't defend herself.
She requires me to defend it and diet
the process to die.
>> So a man at his most weakness is what
when it comes to intimacy. So and both
of them it can be for that as well. So
he calls his wife to bed. Does the
hadith say if she says no force yourself
upon her?
>> No.
>> No. It says the angels will curse her.
Now one second. On what basis is she
saying no? Is it cuz she's on a messes?
>> No.
>> Is it cuz she's really really tired?
>> Is it cuz she's pregnant?
>> No.
>> It is. Do you know what that shows?
She's the narcissist who's using sex as
a tool to punish him.
>> Yeah. And and the
>> what happened, sister?
>> And another thing, another thing.
>> If the husband goes and plays around
>> Yes.
>> Then what she's going to say?
>> Just what you mean? Like it's a capital
punishment on him.
>> Cun is too much. Woman, woman, woman.
>> Yeah. You know they they go spam out but
let me get something he's
got capital punishment. Yeah. So subhan
Allah and not only that she I'll give
something knock out any man it is let me
tell you something this with men it's
death blood if a if if a man for example
if you come home for example a man this
happened the time of the prophetam he
came and saw his wife having sex with
another man he comes to the messenger of
Allah
>> he tells him
>> and he says I have seen listen carefully
I have seen my wife have intimacy
fullblown intimacy with another Man, the
prophetam say okay yeah go kill her go
do this go do that you know what he said
to him he said now you are going to get
lashed why because you have four
witnesses
oh but I thought he was defending all
his men men let me get this right as a
man you're going to catch your wife in a
bed with another man come to the m of
Allah and the m of Allah says instead of
saying I'm sorry that's what happened
>> and we're going to go bring her for her
>> and we're going to whatever we're going
to now lash you for slander.
>> Yeah,
>> you're thinking slander. I just saw my
wife and guess what saved them? Wah wahi
came down and lean which is that they
take curse by Allah. You know she look
at this the you know what was to save
the the the the woman and the man they
both take curses by Allah.
>> If he slander her if he slander her the
curse of Allah is on him.
>> What is it? I swear by Allah. Look what
did they say? They said in and the
narration says said wall
I saw it. Sorry. And the fourth one is
what?
Yeah. And
>> do you know what some of the narrations
say? They say when the woman was told to
say the same woman, the same woman in
this instance, she was brought to court,
she said, "I didn't. I didn't. W I
didn't." They said when it came to her
saying, "May the curse of Allah," she
paused. She She paused. Now imagine what
would be going through these people's
mind if she paused, they would say, "Ah,
she's a liar. She stopped stopped up and
then she said, "May Allah's peace be
upon her."
>> Everyone would say, "What?" But what did
Islam say? Some said no. Did she say it?
>> And Subhan Allah. Let me give you the
let me give you the end of the I'm going
to give you the end of this. Tell me
>> when she she had the baby.
>> Yeah.
>> And he was born. The prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sent
>> uh I think
>> said go and look and tell me if the baby
is this, this, and this.
>> Okay. When he came back and he told him
the baby is this and this, the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam knew she
lied. He said if it wasn't for the
>> I would have had her. Subhan Allah. This
is the of the hadith the end of the
hadith. You understand? So, so look look
now she is lying but because of the
>> he would not
>> take the punishment in the dy he lets
her
>> in the if it's a misogynist religion all
about men he would say no bring her here
even from the getgo
>> from the get
>> did you see her let's deal with her
alhamdulillah for Islam and the rights
Islam has been given to to uh to the
woman from the get-go when no one had it
subhan Allah let's carry
What this is subconsciously telling
women is that we're inherently
ungrateful and sinful. The chronic fear
and guilt and shame that's been put in
us is from a very young age. Obey your
husband or be cursed. Your needs don't
matter because obedience is salvation.
Obedience makes you a good person, a
good wife. And if you don't, then
there's no worth.
>> Oh, sorry. Yes, you have to be obedient.
It's as simple as that. You have to be
obedient. Simple as that. Um and it's
made clear and if you
>> ingredient in in halal of course in
halal but if a husband comes and ask his
wife something which is haram
>> of course not that's exactly so the
thing is what this is what Allah and his
messenger simple as that okay as simple
as that the man the man I'm talking
about a real man please don't get
confused with your dad or whatever who
this etc I'm talking generally not this
woman yeah generally who abuses your mom
etc. We're not talking about that kind
of man. A man who does Islamic duties,
etc. There has to be obedience. He is
the bread runner. He's the one out there
who's doing providing for you, doing
everything. That's the reason why the
responsibility is on him and he will be
accountable of their judgment. He
requires obedience. You don't want to
give it no problem. As simple as that.
Allah has measures decreed that and
that's the matter at hand.
>> To anyone, i.e. men. There's a
disconnection between your body and
yourself because the world is telling
you you are filthy. a walking mistake
and that causes illnesses. That causes
mental health issues. That causes
identity crisises. It causes religious
shame and even religious trauma. It
causes selfhate.
You're a walk in temptation. So cover
up. Hide. God forbid a man sees you.
It's always our bodies. It's always what
we wear. It's always us. but never their
thoughts, their eyes, their filthy
brains. Do you guys not question this?
Because the reason why a lot of you
women have so many issues is because of
this disconnect. The world is already
pushing this narrow.
>> Okay, if that's the case, then if why
does Allah say in the Quran, firstly to
the man, tell the believer gaze? Why
does Allah say to the man first before
the woman? Where does Allah say in the
Quran that because men are animals, you
have to cover yourself up? Where do you
get this? Where are you getting this
nonsense from? Okay, we have to cover up
if that's the case. Yes, men know men.
Okay, that's the reason why Allahhana
stipulated certain things to protect
you, to protect your heart. Okay, if you
want to go and live like a liberal
feminist, go out there, go out there and
you're going to see these women who have
been destroyed. Why do you think so many
women come to Islam? Why do you think
majority of the people that come to
Islam are women? If it's so misogynistic
and he hates, you know why? Because the
western women know, they know what true
liberation is in Islam. They know how
they were used, sexually abused. 97% of
British women have been sexually assa um
um assaulted one way or another.
>> You You want to buy You want to
merchandise a car, put a naked woman
next to it. Exactly. You want to
merchandise You want to merchandise
chocolate, a naked woman. You want to
merchandise a drink, naked woman.
>> Exactly. You know what sex is? Is
>> exactly
>> slavery.
>> Exactly.
>> Slavery.
>> And not only that, you are slavery to
the beauty industry, to makeup. My look
at you. Why do you come out of the house
without makeup?
>> Islam. I look at Islam. Who is the first
woman to have the first university in
the world? Do you know what is it?
>> No.
>> In Morocco.
>> In Morocco. Subhan Allah.
>> Who built it? Ali.
>> I don't know.
>> The oppression. They're so oppressed.
>> So oppressed. So she built a university
and had people coming to seek knowledge
there.
>> Yeah.
>> Look, when our women were thriving,
>> the wife of Abu Da
>> she used to have inji
>> in Damascus.
>> Yeah.
>> The daughter of Im Ahmed.
>> Fatima.
>> Yeah.
>> She used to listen
to her father. She used to learn when
her father used to give halakat
>> who look what Muslim women's produced to
us. Immiuhar
no bkari. Yeah. Im Malik.
>> Yes.
>> Im Shafi. These were they didn't have
fathers. Their mother inside.
>> Exactly.
>> You work together. You are in the sight
of Allah. None is better but by
righteousness.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And brothers and
sisters, that's all we have to say.
Inshallah. Alhamdulillah. The rights
Islam has given women400 years ago till
today. The western women were fighting
blood tooth and nails for it. Subhan
Allah. Alhamdulillah for Islam.
Alhamdulillah for the liberation. And
you can see all of the misconceptions
got absolutely debunked. Why? Because it
only takes for you instead of venting
out in an emotional rampage. If only you
took that time that you do this video
and did a bit of research, you would
know, wow, how Islam liberates me, but
no, that emotional rant is now not only
cause you to fall into kufur, even maybe
leave the fault of Islam. That's not me
to judge. Now you are letting people,
the enemies of Islam, use your clips to
attack your religion. And guess what?
Alhamdulillah, the truth is the truth.
And this video will show what that Islam
has honors women and has given their
rights a long time ago. That's all we
have to say and sisters till next time
and remember as Allahh says in the Quran
that the best of you in the sight of
Allah is the righteous ones amongst you
men or women.
>> Until then until next time.